I read this article in front of me for
their 11 stories about keeping secrets
before getting married
so people were like writing in like what
their significant other had hid from
them and they didn't find out until
after merit so here are some of them
this first one says that she had credit
card and student loan debt it was it was
north of 50,000 she was making $9 an
hour at the time took me years to get
that down and she never appreciated the
effort oh yeah the other one is that he
smokes marijuana every day before we got
married we smoked together only a few
times how do you hide that wow that's
hard yeah it smells yeah thank you this
other one that his mother was alive he
gave me a sob story about losing his
mother to a heart attack in a grocery
store and of course I was all about
comforting him we dated and eventually
married but what could he say I lied
about my mother dying so he just kept
her a secret I later found a card from
her to him for his birthday in the
garage wedged in some books I was
horrified to find out I had a
mother-in-law and hadn't invited her to
our wedding we divorced after three
years his mother was a lovely woman and
treated me very kindly knowing I had no
idea and believing I was horrified by
the circumstances she wasn't surprised
at his duplicity and later regretted not
warning me about her son but she had
hoped I'd be a fix for him I wasn't
crazy
this is the reason why I never
understood why people rushed until like
weddings where they have to get married
I'm like if you're gonna plan on spend
spending the rest of your life together
like take your time you don't have to
get married next year or like try to hit
this like arbitrary normal yeah that
could have been a years long gig we
don't know for five years yeah and for
the first four years
my ex-boyfriend had this story when we
first got together the first time he
ever opened up to me that made me be
like oh my god like he talked about his
dad abusing him constantly it when he
was like up till age five and one time
his dad got so mad
he whipped him with a car belt like I
one of those like belts from a car yeah
serpentine Bobby yeah yeah it was like
yeah he kept whipped him with that
because he worked on cars a lot working
with that until he blacked out
unconscious and his mom rushed him to
the hospital and was like Vail he woke
up in the hospital and his mom was the
only one there and that's why because
his mom used to call Ola and so he's
like well I feel like I owe her because
she was always there for me and
childhood and he cried and like he had
these marks on his back like these like
scars yeah and like he was like yeah I'm
so self-conscious about it and like
people would ask me about it when I we'd
had a change in like PE and like it
would always like really hurt like
because I remember like I love my dad
but I can't believe he did that like
when I look at my dad I just him so like
I can't believe that's the same man that
did that and he would just like
constantly like have you've ever brought
it up he would cry and like it got
brought up several times during our
relationship where he would just start
crying and stuff and then four years in
he tells me that never happened to him
what and he tells me that it was a story
that happened to his dad why that like
he like felt connected to and when he
told that story people gave sympathy to
him and that he always had like
depression and like the fact of a story
gave him sympathy like made him telling
it until he kind of adopted it as his
own thank you juicy Smalley aired it
yeah and then the marks I was like but
what about the marks on your back he
said he there were stretch marks because
he got super swollen like and he was
like captain of a football team when he
was in high school and so he had gotten
like he worked out like crazy and he got
like super ripped really fast and then
like lost weight and so they were
actually stretch marks and working out
and he was embarrassed by them so then
he would he was so embarrassed by the
stress stretch mark says he was very
self-conscious about how he merged it
and so he was able to actually have real
emotions become active were you like
what you really were you really
embarrass my stretch marks [ __ ]
no he was like we went to Hawaii we went
to Hawaii he wouldn't go to the beach
because he didn't want to take his shirt
off and I was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
we paid so much money to go to Hawaii
we're not gonna go to the beach yeah but
yeah yeah so it made me yeah it like
broke something and like he already did
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in our
relationship early on but like at this
point we had gotten up past it and he
was really good boyfriend and then he
this this like Santa Mel store that I
would always like coddled him for he
told me like that whole time it was a
lie and then it just broke a trust where
like if you're able to lie about that
for so long and keep a straight line and
the only reason he came clean about it
was he's like I cuz he wanted to marry
me and he's like I just don't want there
to be pain please ray and I and I
respected him for that like I was able
to recognize like that's a respectful
thing to do it was like I didn't want
there to be any lies going into marriage
that's nice but it really did ruin
something yeah we were best friends for
a long time we we were the best friends
in the whole world I also heard about I
heard about this dude that told his
girlfriend that he was a colorblind for
like a whole year
that guy was [ __ ] up and she was like
maybe you should get checked out for
that casually and then later he like
heightened the story like she was like
oh you owe me Dom Dom it's so weird that
he would do that classic no I remember
that cat he used to he was he was he was
he was a nice nice guy he's very long
yeah he used to go up to all of us
tubers at the time and he would like
pull everyone aside and give them the
same speech I introduced no I introduced
okay Wow yeah I introduced him to all of
my YouTube friends one time it was at
the very first VidCon 2010 I was like
huh the first day I spent alone and then
the second day I was like oh it's kind
of weird that I didn't bring him and
like introduced him can I spend so much
time with these YouTube people but like
he's never met them I introduced him to
them one time once we broke up three
months later and he goes up to each one
of them individually calls them or text
them on Facebook with us again
all these numbers well we were all in
the same room so it was like me and
Shane Michael Richard like Gordon
everybody right and so he was going up
to all of us and giving us all the same
speech about how we all inspired him and
like how all the [ __ ] oh yeah but but we
all talk to each other too so were like
yeah we're down the guy came up to us
and said that and then when we broke up
he also instant message or text message
or DM door whatever every person was
like hey I know we're broken up but I
hope we can still be friends you know
like me I have no bad feelings about
something icky or we discern right so he
uses stolen valor from from people who
get abusive friends why are you reached
out to everyone like you were friends
you weren't friends yeah alright it was
odd her next one she had herpes as bad
kitty
found out from her obstetrician when she
was six months pregnant and we went in
for an appointment and his first
question to her was how's the herpes any
flare-ups it's a law now that you have
to tell you appointment being gays in
California there's some [ __ ] about
that no in California there's a lot that
you don't have to tell your partner if
you have HIV
exactly they don't want to stigmatize it
or whatever you're gonna but it's a
thing it's a thing that exists that can
hurt me right that can hurt you a white
stigmatize it's like saying uh
coronavirus like we don't want to
stigmatize coronavirus
there are a lot of people saying that
gay people say that that's that's the
whole thing right if you wait long
enough they'll all be a law about that
in the I'm not even talking about the
politics of it I'm just talking about
you when you see people coughing and
then you're like I don't wanna stay I'm
gonna stay away from that person
coughing over there right that's that's
what I'm talking about I'm with you
that's like the same [ __ ] like how you
doing careful precautious about your own
health but in California you wait six
months you're forced to be with some
three feet within someone corona and
they have to be allowed in a restaurant
yep in California yep just wait yeah
exactly exactly it always eventually
gets there it's the so open-minded your
brain fellow exactly yeah if you're so
open-minded your brain fella
okay this other one it says that he
likes to wear women's clothing not
always in a sexual way either
hey I just came home one day and there
he was sitting in my favorite pair of
panties in my silk robe just playing
video games now we sit around together
playing video games in our panties it's
actually really great season it's before
my friend had that she first of all I
need to know the style of panties with
silk robe yeah the robe I get it I get
the rope like I'm a big fan of silk and
satin like I get more off with the
panties like pantyhose our panties
panties that's just like you just
sitting up as a boy so it's like falling
like just like maybe there's more Beauty
cuts it in half
dick has the one side of fall through
and then the balls have beautiful
testicular cancer you probably by zone
size no she said her penis
maybe she's maybe she's not someone that
wears his girlfriend's clothes with this
someone that wears this girlfriends
clothes all the time like underwear or
tight t-shirts just all kinds of stuff
oh I know that verse yeah yeah he wears
his girlfriend's everything ya know
hours of jackets any older person when
she's nowhere near him Sam Mike who's so
they could be the same size so this
other one that he slept with one of my
bridesmaids
what parenthesis who was his friend
years before we met I wanted to bring it
up to her and ask her how she thought he
was in bed as a joke but decided it
would probably make her too
uncomfortable and lose her lose the
intended humor seems like she was cool
with it yeah she was cool with this yeah
yeah next one that my wife was a virgin
when we first got together oh [ __ ] that
girl
divorce well done so this what he said
we had sex about a week after we started
dating I had no idea we went at it like
rabbits for two years before we finally
got married eventually she told me I had
no I had never asked about previous
partners and never cared I just wish I
had known so I could have made it more
romantic for her first time that's sweet
why would you be against that cuz I want
my woman to have a little [ __ ] in her
pent-up Cornus know that repress that
repressed homemade Christian more and
we're late 20s early 30s I need you to
come in with some on-the-job training I
don't want you starting at the bottom
and I have to teach you everything from
the mailroom I need you to have some
on-the-job whole training you need to
know that certain things I shouldn't be
able to I shouldn't have to tell you I
can't it I can tell you how to amend it
for my liking
but I shouldn't have to teach you how to
ride shouldn't teach you how to get
fellatio obviously I can I can tell you
how to cater it for me you don't like
being dominant you don't like being even
no no no I do I do I just don't want to
start from the ground you like to be
read in yeah I get it because like I
like when I am dumb and he has to teach
me how to do it Oh see the thing cuz I
because I'm sold because I'm so dumb in
a bit like you have to know how to like
give it back to me so it's like later
and take this dick I need you to take it
but I need you still to kind of throw it
back a little bit while I'm doing no -
here's laying down the [ __ ] mark he's
like listen I'm gonna get on all fours
and I want you to [ __ ] build me [ __ ]
you milk me like I'm a cow that has some
like this and then I want you to build
because there's a daylight I also like
he's like I and two years she could
learn a lot all right two years
reporting I made this you can learn a
lot but that's also like you know when
you first get well you're young right
chicks we like what you said it would
hurt but some chicks when they was young
maybe like I'm not thinking that they're
yes that's the answer that's gross and I
imagine doing
with a virgin you're 28 like it's kill
hit like no big like it sounds like she
was horny for it who she sound like she
was ready but how good do you think it
was how good do you think that first hit
was you though because a lot of guys
think they're [ __ ] Slayers and then
they go down there and they do it just
like they did to their ex who loved it
and it's like vaginas are different
everybody's everybody you're gonna be a
noob no matter what on the whole
training if you're a pleaser you know
that everybody is different like I know
some some women prefer the stiff tongue
the slow lick like this some women
prefer it for you to like hold the clip
with your tongue I mean your teeth and
our lips and then kind of go with it
some women some women prefer that
shoulder with your lips breathing in
cool air what you're doing like there
are different ways to do it
that's what you act support that's
catering to it but I have owned the
whole training so I know all of these
different styles I just need you to let
me know what you like what do you want
but that's only because I have owned the
whole training so here's a [ __ ] table
okay he's like listen hey girl
put your hand in the hole Vaseline jar
okay now you're about to fist my butt
but here's why you're gonna do it cuz
I'm a [ __ ] dog that's why I just say
you gotta come with something so I don't
wanna have to deal with a blank I want
something with some eraser marks on it